welcome back everyone this is part four
in our series on analysis methods for
NLP we've come to our third set of
methods causal abstraction I've been
heavily involved with developing these
methods I think they're tremendously
exciting because they offer a real
opportunity for causal concept level
explanations of how our NLP models are
behaving
let's begin with a kind of recipe for
this causal abstraction analysis step
one you state a hypothesis about some
aspect of your target model's causal
structure and you could express this as
kind of a small computer program
in step two we're going to search for an
alignment between variables in this
causal model we've defined and sets of
neurons in the Target Model
this is a hypothesis about how the roles
for those variables and sets of neurons
align with each other
to do this kind of analysis to assess
these alignments we perform the
fundamental operation of causal
abstraction analysis The Interchange
intervention and much of this screencast
is going to be devoted to giving you for
a feel for how interchange interventions
work
for a running example let's return to
our simple neural network that takes in
three numbers and adds them together
we assume that this network is
successful at its task and the question
is in human interpretable terms how does
the network perform this function
as before we can hypothesize a causal
model that's given in green here and the
idea behind this causal model is that
the network is adding together the first
two inputs to form an intermediate
variable S1
and then the third input is copied over
into an intermediate variable W and S1
and W are the elements that directly
contribute to the output of the model
that's a hypothesis about what might be
happening with our otherwise opaque
neural model and the question is is the
hypothesis correct
we're going to use interchange
interventions to help us assess that
hypothesis we'll break this down into a
few pieces first we hypothesize that the
neural representation L3 plays the same
role as S1
let's assess that idea the first
intervention happens on the causal model
so we take our causal model and we
process example one three five and we
get nine we use that same causal model
to process four five six and we get 15.
and now the intervention comes we're
going to Target the S1 variable for the
right hand example that has value 9.
literally take that value and place it
in the corresponding place in the
left-hand example
the causal model is completely
understood by us and so we know exactly
what will happen now the output will
change to 14. the child nodes below the
variable that we intervened on don't
matter in this case the intervention
fully wipes them out and we're just
adding 9 and 5 together
that's the causal model we assume that
we understand it before we begin the
analysis the interesting part comes when
we think about the neural model we don't
know how this neural model works and
we're going to try to use these
interventions to uncover that
so we process 135 with our neural model
and we get nine
we process four five six and we get 15.
and now we're going to intervene on the
L3 State we target that in the right
hand example and we literally take those
values and place them in the
corresponding spot in the left-hand
example
and we study the output and if the
output after that intervention is 14
then we have one piece of evidence that
L3 plays the same causal role as S1
and if we repeat this intervention for
every conceivable input to these models
and we always see this alignment between
causal model and neural model we have
proven that L3 plays the same causal
role as S1 we can continue this for
other variables let's target now L1
suppose we hypothesize that it plays the
same role as W in the causal model
again let's first intervene on the
causal model we target that W variable
on the right hand we take that value and
we place it in the corresponding place
in the left hand model we study the
output that has changed the output to
10. and then we return to our neural
models parallel operation Target L1 on
the right
take that value and literally place it
into the corresponding spot in the left
and we study the output and again if the
output is 10 we have a single piece of
evidence that L1 and W are causally
aligned in this way
and if we repeat this intervention for
every possible input and always see this
correspondence we have proven that L1
and W play the same causal roles and we
could go one step further suppose we
think about L2 suppose we intervene on
L2 in every way we can think of and we
never see an impact on the output
behavior of the model in that way we
have proven that L2 plays no causal role
in the input output behavior of this
network
and since we can assume that the input
variables are aligned across causal and
neural models and we can assume that the
output variables are aligned we have now
fully proven the all these intervention
experiments that that causal model in
green is an abstraction of the otherwise
more complex neural model and that is
exciting if we have actually established
this then we are licensed to allow the
neural model to fall away and we can
reason entirely in terms of the causal
model secure that the two models are
causally aligned they have the same
underlying mechanisms
now that is a kind of ideal of causal
abstraction analysis there are a few
things from the real world that are
going to intervene the first is that we
can never perform the full set of
interventions for all realistic cases
there are too many inputs even for the
case of my tiny addition Network there
are there's an infinitude of possible
inputs we can't check them all so we
have to pick a small subset of examples
and then otherwise for Real Models we're
never going to see perfect causal
abstraction relationships because of the
messy nature of naturally trained models
that we use
so we need some graded notion of success
and I think interchange intervention
accuracy is a good initial Baseline
metric for that
the IIA is the percentage of interchange
interventions that you performed that
lead to outputs that match those of the
causal model Under The Chosen alignment
so you can think of it as an accuracy
measure for your hypothesized alignment
IIA is scaled in 0 1 as with a normal
accuracy metric
it can actually be above task
performance this is kind of striking and
it has happened to us in practice if the
interchange interventions put the model
into a better State than it was in
originally then you might actually see a
boost in performance from these
Frankenstein examples that you have
created
this is really fundamental here IIA is
extremely sensitive to the set of
interchange interventions that you
decided to perform if you can't perform
all of them you have to pick a subset
and that will be a factor in shaping
your accuracy results in particular pay
particular attention to how many
interchange interventions should change
the output label those are the ones that
are really providing causal insights
because you see exactly what should
happen in terms of changes once you have
performed the intervention
so having an abundance of these causally
insightful interventions is the most
powerful thing you can do in terms of
building an argument
let me Briefly summarize some findings
from causal abstraction these are mostly
from our work
fine-tuned Bert models succeed at hard
out-of-domain examples involving lexical
entailment and negation because they are
abstracted by simple monotonicity
programs and I emphasize because and I
wrote it in blue there because I am not
being casual with that causal language I
really intend a causal claim that is the
kind of thing that causal abstraction
license use you to be able to say
relatedly fine-tuned Bert models succeed
at the mqnli task because they find
compositional Solutions mqnli is the
multiply Quantified nli Benchmark it's a
synthetic Benchmark full of very
intricate compositional analyzes between
quantifiers and modifiers and so forth a
challenging Benchmark and we show with
causal abstraction that models succeed
to the extent that they actually find
compositional solutions to the task
models succeed at the mnis pointer value
retrieval task because they are
abstracted by simple programs like if
the digit is six then the label is in
the lower left
a brief digression there I love these
kinds of explanations that simple
program that I described is more or less
a description of the task and so it's
wonderfully reassuring to see that our
explanations actually align with the
task structure for these very successful
models and another nice Point here is
that we're starting to see a blurring of
the distinction between neural models
and symbolic models after all if you can
show that the two are aligned via causal
abstraction then there really is no
meaningful difference between the two
which leads you to wonder whether
there's truly a meaningful difference
between symbolic Ai and neural AI they
can certainly come together and you see
them coming together in these analyzes
finally Bart and T5 use coherent entity
and situation representations that
evolve as the discourse unfolds lead all
2021 used causal abstraction in order to
substantiate that claim very exciting to
see
if you would like to get Hands-On with
these ideas I would encourage you to
check out our notebook it's called IIT
equality it walks through causal
abstraction analysis using simple toy
examples and then also shows you how to
apply IIT which is the next topic we'll
discuss
there isn't time to cover this in detail
but I did want to call out that causal
abstraction is a toolkit corresponding
to a large family of intervention-based
methods for understanding our models
I've listed a few other exciting entries
in this literature here and if you would
like even more connect connections to
the literature I recommend this blog
post that we did which kind of relates a
lot of these methods to causal
abstraction itself
so let's return to our summary scorecard
we're talking about intervention-based
methods I claim that they can
characterize representations richly
after all we show how those
representations correspond to
interpretable high-level variables
I've also tried to argue that this is a
causal inference method
and I still have a smiley under improved
models I have not substantiated that for
you next but that is the next task Under
The Heading of interchange intervention
training
so let's turn to that now IIT
the method is quite simple and builds
directly on causal abstraction with
interchange interventions here's a kind
of summary diagram of interchange
intervention using our addition example
with the one twist that you'll notice
that my intervention now for L3 has led
to an incorrect result we wanted 14 and
we got four
so we have in some sense shown that our
hypothesized alignment between these
variables is not correct
but I think you can also see in here an
opportunity to do better we can correct
this misalignment if we want to after
all we know what the label should have
been and we know what it was
and that gives us a gradient signal that
we can use to update the parameters of
this model and make it more conform to
our underlying causal model under this
alignment
let's see how that would play out right
we get our error signal and that flows
back as usual to the hidden States L1 L2
and L3
and for L1 the gradients flow back as
usual to the input States and the same
thing is true for L2 but for L3 we have
a more complicated update we have
literally copied over the full
computation graph in the pi torch sense
including all the gradient information
and so we what we get for L3 is a kind
of double update coming from our current
example as well as the source example
which also processed that representation
so we get a double update the result of
repeatedly performing these IIT updates
on these models using the causal model
for the labels as we've done here is
that we push the model to modularize
information about S1 in this case in the
L3 variable
so the importance of alignments kind of
Falls away and the emphasis here is on
actually pushing models improving them
by making them have the causal structure
that we have hypothesized in the hopes
that they will then perform in more
systematic ways and be better at the
tasks we've set for them
findings from IIT
we showed that IIT achieved
state-of-the-art results on that mnist
pointer value retrieval task that I
mentioned before as well as rescan which
is a grounded language understanding
benchmark
we also showed that IIT can be used as a
distillation objective
where essentially what we do is distill
teacher models into student models
forcing them not only to conform in
their input output Behavior but also
conform at the level of their internal
representations under the
counterfactuals that we create for IIT
this is exciting to me because I think
it's a powerful distillation method and
it also shows you that the causal model
that we use for IIT can be quite
abstract in this case it's just a kind
of high level constraint on what we want
the teacher and student models to look
like
we also showed that IIT can be used to
induce internal representations of
characters in language models that are
based in subword tokenization and we
show that this helps with a variety of
character level games and tasks this is
IIT being used to strike a balance sub
word models seem to be our best language
models but we have tasks that require
knowledge of characters and what we do
with IIT is imbue these models with
knowledge of characters in their
internal States
and finally we recently used IIT to
create concept level methods for
explaining Model Behavior that's a
technique that we call causal proxy
models and it essentially leverages the
core Insight of IIT
again we have this course notebook IIT
equality it covers abstraction analyzes
and then also shows you how to train
models in this IIT mode
so we can return to our scorecard now I
have smileys across the board and I
claim that I have Justified all of those
Smileys and I feel that this does point
to intervention-based methods as the
best bet we have for deeply
understanding how NLP models work